how many is too many in your formulation
should america just say okay let's have
150 million people move to america
as a compassionate person as someone
with empathy
it is not my job to tell people how big
they can dream
all right uh welcome back uh to this
installment of
uh devil's advocate i'm your host skyler
turton and
okay um today we have a guest uh
freedom main radio he's a blogger and uh
uh noted anti-immigrant activist uh
stephen molyneux how are you sir
i'm very well how you doing today i'm
doing well uh
thanks for being here and is that is
that free domain radio is that
uh is that dot tv uh no
just freedom radio dot com uh i also
wanted to imagine that
i just wanted to comment that i'm going
to assume that your stance on
immigration goes along with the highly
french mustache
that you have going on here so i think
we know where we are in terms of the uh
the uh the boxing ring yeah well i'm not
necessarily
uh up to date on france's immigration
policy if that's what you're talking
about oh
that was an attempt to humor okay got it
sorry uh well you know listen not all
interviews can get off to a great start
so let me ask you um stephen
why uh are you so opposed to
immigration to immigrants in particular
well what have you heard because what
you've heard may not be my actual
position where where are you coming from
in your analysis of my analysis
well i mean listen you're you're the
guest here so why don't you tell us what
you think about immigrants immigration
obviously you're
you're an alt-right activist obviously
you learn more of the right than most
people
uh i don't think that's a secret i don't
want to misrepresent you
so uh what's your stance on immigration
so i'm anti-immigrant i'm an alt-right
activist but you do
you don't want to misrepresent me all
right well i don't listen i'm gonna
either floor it
go on all right so the way
that immigration should work in a free
society is you should be able to go
anywhere you want but you should not be
able to compel
other people to fund your movement right
so for instance
i should be able to take a taxi anywhere
i want in a city
but i should not be able to hold someone
up at gunpoint to get my taxi fare
and the problem with immigration at the
moment is not the movement of people
the problem with immigration at the
moment is the movement of money at
gunpoint to fund
the movement of people so people who
come to western countries as a whole
get huge amounts of welfare get huge
amounts of free housing get free
education get free health care all of
these things are paid for
by existing taxpayers and that is
compelled
transfer of funds okay and the problem
really is not the movement of people
it's the coercive redistribution of
money sure well first off
you know i was going to say surprise but
it's antonym day uh it's completely
expected that you compared uh
people searching for a better life for
their family here in the united states
to uh cab jackers to carjackers so
thank you for that i think we're off to
a great start i want to make sure that
you're not
actually that are you hang on hang on
hang on okay all right
present my argument okay no no don't
miss don't don't misrepresent my
argument
otherwise i might be in grave danger of
thinking that you're not listening to me
which you know doesn't bode well for an
interview what i said was
i'm not saying that they're carjackers
i'm saying it's not fair to steal money
for your cab fare not that you rip the
cab driver out of the seat and drive off
yourself the analogy is somewhat
important
okay well you use the term gun point my
point is just this violent inflammatory
language
i don't think we need to start off with
that off the bat but listen different
strokes
um so let me ask this is am i going to
understand that your problem
that is not with people entering the
country illegally it is
simply the burden that they place in the
taxpayer it's the redistribution that's
your that's your your issue your primary
issue then
well now it feels a little bit like
we're slithering past a rather important
fork in the road
because you started off talking about
immigration and now you're talking about
illegal immigration well i guess it's
oxymoron day as well as antonym day
because illegal immigration
is like saying legal rape or legal theft
i mean it's actually immigration is
legal
according to the laws of the host
country illegal immigration is a
contradiction in terms
so if we're going to start talking about
illegal immigration that's a whole
different matter but did you
like did we deal with all legal
immigration first now we're going to
move on to illegal immigration is that
the plan
well we were talking about migrants
we're talking about immigrants we're
talking about people who are trying to
seek a better life in this country so
yeah i just wanted to make sure that i
understand that you have a problem with
redistribution
uh forced redistribution compelled of
wealth let's say
immigrants uh or natural born citizens
so then would it be your position let's
say to allow immigrants who are not yet
citizens to come here if they're
contributing members as opposed to let's
say um families in west virginia who are
you know benefiting from welfare do we
deport all the you know trailer park
folks here in this country because
they're doing that or is it just when it
comes to brown
people i just want to make sure i
understand well i mean you're assuming
that nobody in west virginia can get a
tan which i think is not
accurate but um no the purpose is of
course the the welfare state was a
massive step in the wrong direction
uh in western civilization and the
welfare state as it stands i mean if you
count it for old people it's post-second
world war
if you can't afford quote poor people
then it's po like sort of 1960s and
onwards
it was a huge mess it was a huge mistake
and of course everyone says well you
know america is a nation of immigrants
it's like well yeah but they came
when there was no welfare state when
they had to rely on their whole and hard
labor on their communities and so on to
to get started in life or to get going
which is why between a third and a half
of immigrants to america in the 19th
century went back home because they
didn't really like it
it's one thing to come to america
because you're attracted by the beacon
of freedom
and free markets and limited government
and low taxation and liberty and
first amendment second amendment all of
the good things that america put into
its constitution and legal system
it's quite another thing to come for
free stuff coming for freedom
is good coming for free stuff is bad so
i think that the welfare state is a
disaster for immigrants it's a disaster
for taxpayers and it's also a disaster
for native born people in west virginia
freedom versus free stuff i'd really be
thrilled if i were into sound bites but
i want to go back to that point of um
our sort of you mentioned the people who
came here originally uh
people the original settlers uh
originally we are we are a nation of
immigrants let me ask you uh
since you wanted to delineate between
legal and illegal immigrants
those people you're talking about they
come here illegally
sorry which people come here illegally
well the people who first came to this i
mean i'm assuming we're not unless we're
talking first nations are we talking
first nations
oh so i see what you mean so the
universe yeah smallpox blankets right
that's a
that's a legal immigration as we're
talking about the starting point i mean
i just want to make sure you know the
smallpox blankets thing is a complete
myth right
they didn't even have a germ theory back
in the day uh there's no evidence that
it was ever used as germ warfare
in fact as soon as inoculations were
available for smallpox they were given
to the native population nobody wanted
them to die
it's like saying well you see the the
native population in north america gave
the europeans
syphilis and tobacco and therefore that
was a kind of genocide it's like now
these this you know the communication of
diseases and
people who hadn't been exposed to each
other's pathogens in the past you know
it was just
it was a huge massive there's a huge
problem uh and the idea that we're going
to try and take current
legislation regarding immigration and
throw it backwards in time half a
millennia i don't think it's a
particularly productive discussion well
my only point is we say we're a nation
of immigrants and then we talk about the
difference between legal immigrants and
illegal immigrants
uh we are a nation of illegal immigrants
they didn't come here legally they
conquered and committed genocide and
then all of a sudden we want to close
the books
i don't think it's consistent so let me
ask you this what do you think should be
done so hang on are you saying that it
was
bad for the europeans to come to north
america that it was some
a break in moral law yes i certainly
think that genesis okay so then we
should if that's your argument we should
not allow it to continue
like so that's in the past we can't do
anything about that but if you consider
coming to other people's lands or other
people countries to be a bad thing
then surely you should support stopping
it now because two wrongs don't make a
right if you find something wrong in
history you should want to prevent it
from occurring
in the present right well and if i had
the foggiest idea or inkling
as to this notion that these people
right now coming here in caravans or
fleeing persecution in syria are trying
to conquer us and commit genocide
as we did first nations i'd agree with
you the contrast is
they came here to kill these people are
coming here for a better life so
i think uh we should afford them that
how do you know that they're coming for
a better life
that's why most immigrants come to
united states would you disagree you
just talked about how great the country
is
well sure but coming here for a better
life can mean that you want to come
and work and contribute to the society
or for immigrants as a whole
particularly from
mexico and central america the vast
majority of them end up on welfare
so it's one thing to say i want a better
life because i wish to pursue
all of the free market opportunities to
manifest my brilliance in in trade
or you want to come and squat on the tax
payers dime
that's you know looking for a better
life
but that's not the right way to look for
a better life like if there's some
criminal who goes and squats in some
rich guy's house while the rich guy is
out on vacation you say hey man
he's just looking for better housing
well yes but but is it moral what he's
doing
well i certainly think that uh obviously
one is i will i will concede that one is
preferable right
but would you can see that both are
preferable to genocide
that's my point um why wait why are we
bringing genocide in
again if we're talking about whether
it's migrant caravans where they're
talking about
refugees from syria uh i i don't think
that their intent
is nearly as severe as that of the white
man who took it from the first nations
who
nearly wiped out an entire race of
people and that's the basis
the intent the intent of the westerners
or the europeans who came to north
america was never to wipe out the
domestic population
ever they traded uh they they bought
land from them legitimately the same
thing happened in south africa
and unfortunately up to 90 of the
natives were killed by the smallpox
virus which had also
ravaged europe for many centuries in
fact thousands of years
and unfortunately the native population
fled
thus carrying the virus and by the time
the europeans got to most of the
villages
most of the population had been killed
by this terrible virus which is a
horrible tragedy throughout history but
it's not the conscious application
of the idea of genocide at all and it's
incredibly disrespectful to everybody
who was involved
in the settling of north america to say
that they were all nazis it's simply
incorrect and it's irresponsible for us
i didn't bring up the word nazi at all i
brought up the word genocide oh no
you're right we brought we brought
smallpox smoke
the nazi imagery we brought smallpox and
they gave us vitamin c so they helped or
scurvy we
but you know anyway you cut it so let's
let's go with this now let me ask you
this
donald trump's policy on immigration
obviously you've been a supporter of his
um are you a supporter of his platform
on immigration or or
let me be more specific i guess since he
hasn't really done a whole lot the
platform that he
ran on uh what's your stance on that
what do you think we should do
uh in dealing with immigration today
oh i think america needs to vastly
reduce the amount of immigration that's
going on
at the moment and there was i think a 30
or 40 year period from the 1920s to the
1960s
where america had almost no net
immigration at all and america survived
and did all right
and because america has been taking what
a million legal immigrants
a year and a couple hundred thousand
illegals coming into the country for
decades now
so at some point you have to get you
have to have a chance to digest your
meal you know you're in some lovely
buffet
uh in a cruise line and you're eating
like crazy at some point you have to
stop
unless you're gonna go full roman
vomitorium on everyone so at some point
you have to stop and see if you can
digest
and this huge experiment on whether the
american character can survive endless
waves of third world immigration
well it remains a conjecture and a
really shaky conjecture as to whether
it's even going to work
so at some point you have to stop taking
people in and you have to start
assimilating the people who are already
here so i think
trump doesn't go nearly far enough with
regards to immigration of course the
border should be sealed because right
now
immigration is a giant welfare program
so building a wall you support
building a wall i want to be i want to
make sure i understand you correctly
you're pro build a wall
sure yeah absolutely um okay and
if i'm not if i'm not misunderstanding
you're saying you'd go further than
donald trump just
no immigration at all to the united
states right now
well i mean i would say let's start with
zero and then see how close
we can get to it for you know 10 or 20
years to find
because right now the people who are
coming into america
are not in alignment with traditional
american values as a whole i mean
there's lots of exceptions individually
but
we have to make group decisions when
we're looking at large numbers of people
so the hispanics who are coming in are
voting overwhelmingly
for large governments socialism and
they're very anti-libertarian the people
coming in from the third world are the
same way and they that's why the left is
importing them not because they like
them
but because they know they're going to
vote for the left this is a form of
cheating
when it comes to elections it's stuffing
the ballot through immigration and it's
subsidizing the growth of government
by taking money from taxpayers and
redistributing it to immigrant groups
that is not an argument that is simply
a a cheat mechanism so yeah it needs to
stay low
because the american um experiment was
small government
uh free speech uh gun ownership and so
on that was the american
and the the immigrants do not match
those values and if you keep getting
more and more
immigrants they don't assimilate they
simply create enclaves within the larger
society and then work to gain political
power
okay uh i don't necessarily agree with
you on all those points but i want to
i want to hone in on some of you just
talked about the first amendment the
second amendment libertarianism people
migrating here who don't have respect as
you said for for freedom
and and the ideas uh of i think you said
traditional american
values i.e white but let me ask you um
about the 14th amendment
isn't it hypocritical when you're
talking about a president who's looking
to repeal potentially the 14th amendment
on birthright citizenship with an
executive order why don't
why don't conservatives why don't
libertarians have a problem with that
but the 14th amendment did not guarantee
birthright citizenship it was never
designed to deal with illegal aliens the
entire point of the 14th amendment was
to prevent the democrats in the south
and stripping away the the rights of the
newly freed black slaves
and so that's what they wanted to say it
was that all the people born inside the
united states and subject
to the jurisdiction thereof which means
part of the civil society the legal
society so the only
people who can be american citizens
are those who are born under the ages of
american laws in other words existing
legal residents
of america so uh the this was actually i
think in 1982 it was basically put in as
a footnote
by what i understand as a fairly lefty
supreme court justice
it was never put to a referendum it was
never put to a vote
the american population was never asked
about it it was simply inserted
through a leftist piece of hysterical
judicial activism and it had nothing to
do with the 14th amendment whatsoever
and since the left does not allow this
to be adjudicated
in any kind of referendum or any kind of
general uh vote then yeah
i mean that which is imposed through
legislative fear can be surely rejected
through that just little fear as well
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander
as they say okay so a lot of words there
so you support the executive order
appealing the 14th amendment from trump
i want to make sure you understand that
yeah i'm pretty sure you didn't listen
to any of them because i just rebutted
the argument that he's repealing the
14th amendment and you just kind of
skated past like i hadn't said anything
but
i do understand that you are sucking on
your gala twice
um the migrant caravan right now
uh why so much fear-mongering this is
something that i think
you know we talk about fake news right
um these people come into the united
states let me ask
this what would you do with these people
right now
these are human beings coming to the
united states seeking a better life
they're on their way
they arrive stephen molyneux
does what well i don't know what you
mean
when you say what would i do with these
people i mean i i don't understand what
you mean well
you know okay we're talking about
language that matters we talked about
natural uh
born citizen uh okay here you know we do
actually have a uh responsibility to
help asylum seekers
refugees these people and they carry men
they're refugees
no they're not no absolutely not they're
they're fleeing
hang on hang on you've got to get the
law down on this stuff if you want to
start discussing this stuff you need to
do more than
you know skim the headlines of leftist
mainstream media outlets
so they're not refugees first of all
honduras is not in a state of civil war
they're not and even war itself does not
make you a refugee you have to be
specifically
fleeing persecution based upon your
religion on your race on your gender or
something like that and none of that is
occurring on honduras even if it was
even if it was they get to mexico the
whole point
of being a refugee is you must apply for
refugee status in the first safe country
you come to
mexico is a safe country for these
people the fact that they're going
through mexico to get to america
automatically disqualifies them as
refugees so honduras is not targeting
them
for their religious beliefs or their
ethnicity because they're pretty much
indistinguishable from a lot of people
in honduras so they're not being
targeted and they're not taking asylum
in the first countries is absolutely
false spent a lot of time in honduras
you spend a lot of time there i'm sorry
spent a lot of time in honduras too i'm
just wondering how you know
how the entire uh makeup of a country
looks unless you spend a lot of time
there
yeah so they are fleeing look up
demographics uh online you actually have
to visit every single place differently
no because it's like passionate
individuals you have to go to the sahara
to find out if it's a desert and warm i
don't quite understand
don't you see this as an educated person
doesn't need to go everywhere to find
out facts
bro you just referred to an entire you
just referred to
people as a demographic do you not see
how this is a part of
the problem we're talking about human
beings i mean we're putting we're
talking about a president who puts human
beings children
in cages separating them from their
parents and by the way according to your
own definition of
asylum then i guess we're totally cool
with the syrian
come on man the president doesn't put
people in cages the uh
the children are separated from the
people who cross the border because they
can't prove
paternity and also because there are
deportation proceedings that may occur
for the parents that have a different
time frame
so uh it is the parents who it's like
saying if if someone goes and robs a
bank and then gets thrown in
jail the court system is just just
just separating families for no reason
it's like well if you commit an illegal
act like crossing a border without
permission
you're the one who's breaking up your
family not the people who are have to uh
enforce the laws of the government
they're not the ones putting the kids in
cages
who who is not the ones putting parents
even if they come here illegally
are not putting their children in cages
that's that's donald trump sure they are
because they're the ones making the
decision that ends up with the children
being segregated they're not being put
in cages they end up with the do the
parents
make decisions which result in the
children being
segregated from the parents so it is the
responsibility of the parents for
breaking the law
they're the ones who are putting the
effect putting the sequence of events in
motion that end up with their children
being separated from them
if they are in fact even their children
because sometimes this can't even be
proven they could be child traffickers
they could be
people using children as drug mules
there could be any number of horrible
things
going on as you know 80 of the women who
try to cross the border are sexually
assaulted it is a
horrible horrible anarchic situation out
there on the border so who knows
whether these are your solution is to
turn them right back
if 80 are sexually assaulted your
solution is to send them right back out
into the cold
oh that is hang on first of all mexico's
not cold but secondly
uh the solution of course has to be more
than just what's right there
in front of your face right so the
solution is if the wall is built and if
the immigration laws are enforced
people will stop trying to cross the
border which means the number of sexual
assaults will go down
enormously it is the poorest border that
is drawing people across
that is resulting in untold numbers of
women being sexually assaulted and to
children being used
as as as pedophile toys and all these
horrible things that are occurring
because of this porous border
it's not because we hate people or it's
not because america wants to just spit
in people's faces
if you let the caravan through do you
know what you get you get another
caravan
and you get another caravan and you get
another caravan and they get more
aggressive they get better armed these
caravan members are vastly
and helping them compassionately what a
[ __ ] nightmare
i'm sorry i said oh no you mean we'd be
letting people in
compassionately who are fleeing uh
countries for a better life here in the
united states what a nightmare
stefan see uh yeah let's bring the
character let's bring in the characters
just out of curiosity just out of
curiosity
what does it cost you if people come
into the country i mean are they coming
to live in your house are they uh eating
your food
are they taking your doctor's visits
that you can't then go to because the
doctors are overworked
just out of curiosity because you seem
to have a lot of compassion i suppose
but what is it costing you personally to
actually exercise
this compassion or are you just
basically shouting nice platitudes into
a void and expecting other people to
step up and pay are you delivering free
education to these kids are you going to
get deliver free dental care
to these people i mean are you putting
them up in your house i mean
you're just saying stuff but there's
nothing it doesn't no let me answer your
question it doesn't cost me any more
than it costs you because as a society
we agree to a certain set of moral
standards for example
we agree that we build roads we agree
that we have a military we agree that we
have a police force and i would like to
see included in those
moral standards and the societal clause
helping those who are less fortunate who
are coming here
fleeing persecution people who are
refugees but i know we're not going to
agree on the honduras hang on hang on
hold on let me so let me ask you the
syrian refugees then were cool because
clearly they would fall under
uh asylum seekers so you're cool on
bringing in
refugees from the middle east right wait
are you saying that
america is the closest country for
people in syria to find safe haven
if they're the only ones who will take
them no that's not the way that the
legal system works with regards to
refugees
so i mean the syrian situation is a mess
unfortunately or fortunately or whether
you like it or not the reality is that
a country being at war does not grant
anybody refugee status
and so the idea that they're refugees
because there's a civil war going on
there
i think that the way that the refugees
or the the uh the syrian situation
should be
dealt with is america should get out of
syria and
they should find people in the
government who helped support
and armed the rebels in syria a lot of
whom turned out to be isis because that
is
funding a terrorist organization which
as far as i understand it pretty
criminal
so i think that uh the american
politicians uh and
you know the ones who jump to my mind uh
the top of the obama administration
secretary of state clinton
ex-secretary of state clinton and so on
well they should be pursued to find out
if they did in fact
send material aid to terrorist
organizations should be dealt with
legally appropriately and then hopefully
the situation in syria
can calm down and let's include
president trump that in that uh
for defending his best buddies here in
saudi arabia some of the biggest funding
funders of terrorism on the globe so
yeah let's let's absolutely agree on
that i do not think that america should
be selling any weaponry to saudi arabia
which is
a horrible funder of of terrorism and
a horrible theocracy that regularly
attacks its own people
right and donald trump was the only one
who defended them when they uh killed
somebody in interrogation which i just
find incredibly
interesting one thing else something
else i find interesting here is
you talk about obviously the board with
mexico and i understand that this is
based off of
we were discussing the caravan that's
fair but it seems like you get really
concerned just with
the mexican border you talked about how
people can come in and out you know we
don't necessarily know who's coming in i
understand that too because it's not
just mexico it's people who could be
coming from south america the honduras
but that same token same thing could be
happening in canada we don't know who's
coming in from canada
but i notice that the right wing the
alt-right conservatives libertarians
don't seem to be pushing
for a wall which wouldn't work which
we'll get to in a second between the
united states and canada
only when it involves brown people
why's that
well i would assume that it's kind of
like triage
you know like if you're a doctor on a
battlefield you try and deal with the
people you can save who are in dire
medical condition you don't necessarily
deal with the people who've got
a minor head wound or a sprained finger
and so when it comes to
sealing up america's borders and
controlling illegal immigration the vast
majority of it of course is occurring
on the southern border so that's kind of
where you go to
first now of course if it starts to
become a problem in the northern border
and the
i feel like i should cough here at this
point in the video but
uh then i'm sure people will turn their
attention to the northern border as well
but
uh it's not racist it's simply a
rational prioritization
of where the major issues are coming
from oh if it's a rationale like that i
guess you know i understand we probably
don't have as many canadian immigrants
because they do have a better quality of
life and healthcare so
i think that's fair we can agree on some
common ground there uh
let's go back to the idea of a wall you
know half of illegal immigrants just
overstay visas
a wall wouldn't work why all of a sudden
do conservatives want to get loose with
the purse strings when it comes to
building a wall again on a border with
with brown people they don't want to get
loose with the purse strings when it
comes to taking care of our children
who need health care who need education
but uh
spending on something that hasn't proven
effective to work to keep out to scary
brown people
all of a sudden we get a little loose
with the budget
so what you're saying if i understand
this correctly is that the wall
might only deal with half the problem
well
yeah there's no proof that a wall would
work and it would cost the taxpayer
uh billions upon billions upon billions
if not trillions of dollars yeah
wait you think it cost trillions of
dollars to build the wall okay let's go
with billions
okay well first of all the cost benefit
justification for the wall is very
simple
in that hundreds of billions of dollars
cost for illegal immigration in america
every year because of this
redistribution of
income at the point of a gun that i
talked about at the beginning so but you
then said you didn't talk about right
so it's it's easy to justify it from a
cost standpoint let's say that it does
only
tamp down on half the problem a
government solution that deals with half
the problem
is a very rare government solution
because most of the government solutions
make the problem worse
now if you think that a wall doesn't
work you have kind of a problem
because there's so many examples both in
history and in the modern world of walls
working very very well
there was hadrian's wall um which kept
the roman army
uh at bay the china built the entire
chinese wall which has been very
effective the only place now the only
human structure visible from space i
think other than my own forehead
and uh if you look at the wall and there
you go israelis building yeah the wall
that israel is building
is uh very uh effective there are walls
around prisons that seem to work
quite well and i see a wall behind you
in fact it seems to be keeping people
out
so the idea that a wall doesn't work is
just a false
think of uh east and west berlin right i
mean uh or think of eastern west germany
there were walls all around
the the communist enclaves to keep
people in and they worked
extraordinarily well it doesn't mean no
one got out
but if there hadn't been a wall just
about everyone would have gotten out no
listen i agree with most of uh
most everything you just said there's
common ground you pointed to examples
in communist china uh uh
communist when you talk about uh east
and west germany uh and you want to
go their direction i say maybe go a
different direction well um
technically the chinese wall was not
built under the communists it predated
them by
well quite a long time yeah well okay
listen whatever you want to go the
direction of of china and uh
in east germany cool i uh i disagree not
only i think you proved the point that
not only do walls keep
uh people out and people who could
invent for example the next cure for
cancer we don't know a lot of these
people want to come in and contribute to
the very fabric of america just like all
of us have
uh although again i i check i completely
recognize i'm not first nations i don't
believe you're first nations
either uh but yeah well it's very
ironic for the right to want to pursue
directions that we've seen under under
communist rule again it's
i guess i shouldn't be surprised when
we're talking about spending a bunch of
money
hang on saying that walls work doesn't
mean that all walls
are virtuous like if you say guns shoot
bullets that doesn't mean you agree with
every single
time a gun shoots a bullet you're simply
stating an empirical fact walls do work
and they've been used by bad regimes and
they've been used by good regimes
so saying that there are walls around
berlin under the communists uh therefore
you want america to become like
communists is that
you are a master of misdirection i will
say stephen uh you know right now you
just you use them as examples and i try
to address that point
and then you you know i can do that too
some guns don't shoot bullets some guns
squirt water
some guns shoot squibs some guns uh
shoot blanks like the one that killed
jason lee the point is
uh we can misdirect all we want i'm
using the examples that you brought up
bro and then you just try to distance
yourself from when i think this is
hold
almost got that past me you did a real
cherry pick there right so i talked
about
uh ancient uh china uh i talked about
ancient uh
northern uh uk uh i talked about
uh the germans under under communism and
i also mentioned israel now you talked
about everything except
israel how interesting why do you think
that you wouldn't talk about israel do
you think that israel is wrong in
building walls to keep out illegal
immigration
uh i don't understand exactly if they're
keeping
uh walls to one second here i got some
water bro
um okay i should have test
should have tested that first uh well
this is gonna be a much more fun
interview now
uh israel was the question yeah i want
to make sure i have that correct
uh if i'm not mistaken they're building
walls to keep out palestinian children
with rocks while they uh
uh approach them with tanks well no
there's also
walls to keep out uh some of the people
trying to get in from north africa and
other places so
yeah israel has uh it's more than just
uh the west bank there are walls around
israel that
they're using to keep people from coming
israel who want to be there
sure yeah namely kids who who want to
come in here throwing rocks they need
they need walls and they need
they need an arsenal uh more than than
god to keep out the palestinian children
yeah listen i think it's a great
comparison as well you're comparing the
united states to the
uh israeli occupation in regime
you want to continue on that direction i
think it's right in line with communist
china and
uh and uh germany as you mentioned
uh i think this goes back to the point
we talked about the wall a lot and i
think we just agreed that
there's visa overstays as well as the
law but we don't really hear people
talking
about the visa overstates people talk
about the wall
president trump stirred up rhetoric with
the wall it's become a symbol
again and not saying that president
trump donald trump
uh or you are racist that remains to be
seen but it would seem that the
motivations for a lot of people
as it relates to the wall are certainly
i mean at what point do we say
okay certainly leaning that way when
there's no discussion of visas or budget
just let's build up the wall to keep
out the brown folk i'm sorry was there a
question in there
yeah what point do we acknowledge that
maybe that's a big part of the
underlying motivation
again if we look at the data that we
have we look people don't talk about the
visas which accounts for
the vast majority of illegal immigrants
in this country to use your term they
only talk about the wall
why is it only the wall with mexico and
not people overstaying visas
well i think that a lot of people have
talked about visa overstays
as a big problem and that's something
that needs to be dealt with
but the wall is a little bit easier to
deal with because you've got people
coming across the border you can build a
wall to stop them
and visa overstays is a little bit more
complex and of course once you
have taken uh your resources to build
the wall you'll have me more
resources available to start pursuing
visa overstays so
again it's you know if you're bleeding
from some big cut you deal with that
before you start dealing with a minor
toothache or something i mean you just
have to triage
and deal with things that are more
important but i'm sure you understand
and you know as well as i do that
people visas aren't as important why
aren't visas as important when they're
the majority of illegal immigrants to
overstate visas why isn't that as
important i thought you said it was half
yeah half for the majority depending on
whose numbers you use
all right so but the wall you can build
and deal with that issue
and it's one area where you can stop
people from coming across
figuring out how to deal with the visa
overstays is a bit more of a challenge
because those people are already in
american society they're scattered
they're hard to find whereas a wall is
something you can build
pretty easily and right away and it
doesn't mean like it doesn't have to be
either or you can work on both
simultaneously if you want you know for
instance if america stops
bombing brown people overseas endlessly
i'm pretty sure you'd have enough
resources
to deal with immigration issues in the
host country how about we stop bombing
brown people overseas and rather than
spend billions of dollars to keep brown
people out spend it on health care
and education ah well see the reason for
that and
and this is the question around racism
and it's a very very interesting
question
so if you are a republican let's say i
mean just put this
imagine imagine you were somebody i
don't want to but let's let's
i know just just you know step with me
down the dark path of
of nefariousness if you will so imagine
that you're a republican
yeah and you are looking at as you say
brown people coming into the country
now hispanics for instance
vote overwhelmingly for democrats like
80 percent sometimes higher depending on
the demographic right
so if you are a republican you you must
understand
that having hispanics come into the
country from mexico or central america
is directly against your political
objectives to get lower taxes and a
smaller government right
because they're going to overwhelmingly
vote for
the left for the democrats for the
liberals right so
you understand that having lots of
people come in from mexico central
america
is bad for the republicans and whether
you agree with republicans or not
i obviously know that you don't you at
least have to understand why they would
have opposition to that
because it's really hard to fight you're
the words that are coming out of your
mouth
this is the problem as conservatives
republicans whatever term of the day
you're talking about tearing people up
tearing families apart
for politics this goes beyond politics
you're talking about tearing families
apart putting kids in cages because
republicans don't like that they vote
overwhelmingly democrat even if we talk
about republicans and democrats and
differences in how people vote and yes
it's true hispanics vote overwhelmingly
democrat
most immigrants most young people do
almost all minorities do
surprise the point is there's only one
party republicans who want to tear
families apart over politics the
leftists i'm not sure what you mean by
tear families apart how do republicans
stare families apart again
by trying by right now having a
president who wants to deport people who
are in this country who have been here
for decades who have
children who are legal citizens of this
country
and deporting their parents tearing
families apart has trump actually talked
about
rounding out people and deporting them
yes okay well let's assume that that's
that's all true
so what you're saying is the people who
came into the country illegally
the people who broke america's laws and
crossed the border illegally
have no responsibility whatsoever for
the result of breaking their laws
no i'm not saying they have no
responsibility whatsoever but
republicans have some response
responsibility and republicans
responsibility and intimations of racism
do the people who cross the border and
break the laws
have any responsibility for the
consequences of breaking those laws
of course they do okay no one's saying
they're talking about
only trump and all that what is their
responsibility is it 60 40
is it 70 30 is it 99 100 is it only one
percent i'm just
curious what agency you're giving brown
people
because you seem to think that the brown
people have no agency in their lives
whatsoever that seems about the most
racist statement that i could think of i
think they have agency and i think that
all of us to protect our family and to
feed our family if we were capable of
leaving a country and fleeing oppression
and poverty the united states
would have a moral obligation to do so
so they did commit
they came here without going through the
proper channels as they've been laid out
at this point i'll give you that but the
point is just as you mentioned with work
visas
it's not an issue that we can solve
right away it's not an issue that we can
solve that's why you said you were
pointed the law what i'm saying is we
cannot solve this problem immediately so
why don't we all err on the side of
compassion
and offer a path to citizenship for
these people so that
they can pay for their mistakes they can
become contributing members of
the united states economy and we don't
have to tear them apart from their
children
and put their kids in cages which if
people don't believe me
google kids in cages donald trump not
making it up okay
okay you know i get what you're coming
from and listen i i understand it's a
mess
it's a difficult situation and nobody
relishes the idea of
parents leaving a country when they've
got kids there when they've been nobody
likes this
nobody likes this nobody says yay this
is going to be a great thing but this is
precisely why it should never have
gotten to this point to begin with
like if you're i mean i'm going to take
an extreme example it's not direct but i
want people to sort of understand this
if you are a heroin addict and you've
been a heroin addict for 20 years
it's really really tough to quit it's
horrible to quit and you
you know it might be very bad for your
health to even try to quit
which is kind of why you shouldn't be a
heroin addict for 20 years because it
puts you in a hugely
ugly situation where there's no pleasant
easy
or positive way out and so the fact that
immigration laws have basically been
unenforced
for decades has put america into the
situation
where there's no nice way to deal with
it and
that's why we should blame the people i
just offered a nice way to deal with it
how do you think we do the path to
citizenship for people who are here
especially
uh people who have children who were
born here uh again
people can find a path to citizenship
where they
can pay taxes they can work they can
contribute to our economy which is what
they wanted to do in the first place
right
that's just that's no that's just
another government program and the path
to citizenship
is uh we already saw this under reagan
in california so if you want to turn
the entire country into california you
can work on the path to citizenship
because that was done
under reagan and california has become a
complete basket case where
just about everyone is trying to flee
out of california and you've got needles
and
feces all over the streets and uh cities
collapsing and i mean it's just a huge
mess so no that's not the solution the
solution oh sorry i was under this
ill-conceived notion that it was uh the
most popular state
in the union with the most amount of
people there and the most the biggest
industries i'm sorry
i didn't realize that california was a
fraction the size of rhode island
covered in feces and needles sorry i can
continue i just want to make sure that
i i need to check myself because i
wouldn't want a straw man in california
well right that's an argument i'm just
going to have to kind of brush by
because i'm not really sure what
relevance it has to the facts
that canada that that california went
through this whole process
and so the solution is we have to get
back to private charity if you want to
start talking about compassion and
helping people
you and i are on the same page regarding
that my friend because i want to help
people as much as you do
but the problem is when you use the
government to try and help people
it doesn't help people the welfare state
was brought in to eliminate poverty and
poverty has not been eliminated in fact
poverty has been made worse
there are more poor people in america
now than before the welfare state
families have broken up boy you you want
to keep families together you're
concerned about
family intact staying intact and having
family integrity
i'm the same way if you look at the
black community they had an illegitimacy
race or a single motherhood rate in the
20th
20th percent uh before the welfare state
now it's 75
so families are being destroyed under
the welfare state it's absolutely
terrible
you need private charity to go in work
with people figure out what's best for
them
rather than just firing this cannon of
borrowed money at people to buy their
votes and then pretend that you're
helping people
helping people is a very complex
complicated and difficult thing to do
the government yeah okay maybe it can
build some roads maybe
it can arrest people who speed maybe it
can enforce some basic property rights
it can't do things like march into
dysfunctional communities
and figure out how to make them whole
and healthy again that is the job
of private charity with incentives for
success
so i do want to care i do want to help
the people
i just don't want to do it through the
agency of the state which generally
makes things worse
congratulations on blaming the the
plight of black people and minorities
on new minorities instead of a corrupt
uh system designed right when did i
mention two minorities
designed to continue uh oppression
congratulations on
blaming blaming the problem with black
americans on
new uh migrants coming into this country
rather than the capitalist system that
favors the wealth
yeah you're right listen poverty is
worse because the rich keep getting
richer
and the poor are getting poorer and way
to way to pin that on
a few people coming over in a caravan
awesome
so what would you do then if not offer
them a path to citizenship what do you
do with the 12.5 million people
who are here and who have children
what do you do well you eliminate the
welfare state okay
but like you said you just said it's not
practical to try and get rid of
people who overstate visas you think
it's practical to get rid of the welfare
state overnight right now we have over
12 million
undocumented did you do you want me to
answer the question or not i mean if
you're going to just interrupt with
practicalities
there's no you can say anything's
impractical if you're talking about an
ideal solution
that's what i'm talking about i mean
america eliminated slavery for heaven's
sakes i mean i think the welfare state
can be handled
so let's do it without a civil war but
yes uh it can be handled so
if you get rid of the welfare state and
then the people who need help can get
help
the people who can get jobs will get
jobs people's wages will go
up enormously now the people who are
here just for welfare will return
to mexico of their own volition and of
their own choice
and the people who are here to work well
i don't know let's get rid of the
welfare state and let's see
what happens afterwards because if the
vast majority of people
decamp and go back to mexico well
there's not as much of an issue to solve
is if most people stay and are happy
that they're working instead of being on
the welfare state then that's a whole
different conversation but right now we
don't have any idea
what proportion of people are in either
camp uh
okay could there be common ground if we
let's say
limit the welfare state uh and then at
that point allow uh
immigration as people um please
free to come and go as they let me ask
you this because we're no longer again
if it comes to the problem of
paying for them then the problem isn't
them entering the country it's us
paying for them so in that case if we
eliminate the possibility of us being
burdened to pay for them
then there's no immigration isn't a
problem we can have a more unified world
let me ask you this no according to
recent surveys about 150 million
people want to move to america
[Music]
how many is too many in your formulation
what is the upper limit should america
just say okay let's have 150 million
people move to america
who don't speak english who don't have a
history of of uh
western ideas of separation of church
and state and separation of state and
economy and so on
i'm just curious is there a caravan for
instance let's say the caravan had
five million people in it would you
think that is too many what is the upper
limit for you
in terms of compassion is there any
limit to it at all you said 150 million
people
would like to move to the united states
correct that is correct as a
compassionate person
as someone with empathy it is not my job
to tell people
how big they can dream
okay i'm i'm not looking for a disney
song here i'm looking for actual
practical answers
would you oh sorry i thought you were
offended at the idea of practicality
when i tried to hold you to it earlier
i'm sorry we're back to practice
i'm asking for numbers that's that you
won't ask me for numbers i'll give you
numbers i gave you numbers on the wall
what is the upper limit that you would
accept
of people coming to america in any given
year would you say 150 million is fine
and well less than 150 million a year
would not have coming together talking
about total
yeah it's not my job to tell them how
big they contribute it's not my job to
tell them whether they can
uh uh want to move to the united states
or not
no i don't think that's my place and i
don't think that's the place of people i
know you are here
you should take hang on answer the
question you think that america should
take 7 000
people in the caravan you have no
problem with a million people coming
into america
every year from the third world you have
no problem with hundreds of thousands of
people coming across the border
so we're talking 1.3 1.4 1.5 million
do you think that number should be
higher or lower or stay about the same
with regards to people coming into
america
i don't have a problem with a number
being higher because i don't fear brown
people
that's mine all right so i don't care
where they come from i i am
glad to have them here because i'm
compassionate and because that statue of
liberty
reads give us you're poor you're tired
you're hungry uh it's not my place and i
think it's ironic that for people who
really don't like
uh you know a women's right to choose
they talk about it being women playing
god
want to play god with who can actually
come to this country or not especially
again i don't think you're necessarily
first nations i'm not quite sure
especially when it is based it is
predicated on people
who came to this country and have
occupied it
you and i we are the occupation
we came here and we harmed people it is
not our land
and so for us to act all of a sudden
moral
virtuous righteous that we have a right
to it when we don't
i think is very hypocritical we have
about as much a right to this land as
150 people
a million people who want to move here
so okay so you would you would place no
upper limit on the people who could come
into america regardless of whether there
were enough doctors
regardless of whether there were enough
schools regardless of whether there was
enough housing
regardless of whether there was any
money in the government's coffers to pay
for anything
regardless of any of that you would just
have people come pouring into the
country because it makes you feel good
because it makes you feel compassionate
regardless of whether there's any
infrastructure to handle them
whatsoever regardless of what it does to
wages particularly of poor americans
regardless of what it does to housing
costs particularly to poor americans
you just say open the borders let
everyone in regardless of all of that
now let me ask you this
you say we're occupiers and that's a
terrible thing right
do you think can i ask can i answer that
other question first and then
well there wasn't a question there but
you can certainly respond to it okay all
right well thank you
thank you for the luxury thank you for
granting me the ability to respond to it
uh yeah listen i i i would uh i would
not
i would not i because i don't think that
we are entitled to this land so until
we meet with the chiefs of the original
first nations people maybe they can put
a limit on it they can put a number on
it but
as a citizen of the world as as a
citizen
of the global community you know i've
noticed that you're vacants you talk
about them hurting poor americans well
most poor americans don't have it as bad
as poor the poor in the honduras or
mexico so
i care about them just as much as i care
about poor americans
that would be my answer as a citizen of
the world but continue with your next
point and then we have to go
you know just a bunch of platitudes with
no policy but all right
so let me ask you this do you think
that the war to end slavery
was let's say that the civil war will
take the popular narrative like the
civil war in america
was required to end slavery in the south
do you think that it was a positive
development in the united states that
slavery was eliminated as an institution
i think that slavery could have been
eliminated uh immediately upon the
founding of this country
if it wasn't dominated by white cis
imperialist males
so i would have that problem solved
before a war so i don't think it was
necessary
i think it was necessary because of the
mistakes of the founders who we
love to deify when in fact i think they
could use
a little bit more objective examining
do you believe that wealth or land that
is accumulated
through the exploitation of slavery is
justly owned
no of course not right do you know that
most of the indigenous tribes within
north america
practiced slavery they did not
they did they did not they really did
well that just goes to he said she said
right well he said he said here where
uh people can can run a google search on
this just like with children in cages
you said
this administration's not for children
cages they did
bro i just got like it happened and the
native americans i mean many of them
didn't even have concepts of personal
property so
i don't know how if you don't have a
content of personal property you enslave
somebody as
property uh i don't know maybe when they
saw the
the europeans come in and start scalping
people they got a little got a little
bow and arrow shy but
no they didn't enslave each other not
like we did
well let me ask you this if it's true
that the indigenous population practiced
slavery
then wouldn't that mean that their
ownership of the land and the prophets
of slavery
was illegitimate yeah well that's a new
point because they didn't practice
slavery that was a white man who brought
it with him
so are you saying that non-whites don't
practice slavery
no that's trying to understand your i
didn't say no i said there i said the
white man brought it with him
to this land the you that which became
the united states the colonialists the
imperialists at that
point they were a peaceful culture sure
you had ever you did have people who
would get into conflict that'll happen
when you have nomadic
and you have sedentary tribes right but
that's not the same as enslaving people
not to the degree that it happened on a
massive scale again through systemic
oppression from colonialism and
imperialist they didn't do it
so i don't think it's a fair comparison
between what
they had done and then what the settlers
who then became
later on the founding fathers of the
united states like george washington
and thomas jefferson people who had
slaves working in their house
had done i think they have more rights
let me ask you this then
okay so let me ask you this this doesn't
require
accepting basic historical facts so
let's go with this
do you think that a culture that fought
hard to end slavery
and has apologized for slavery and
regret slavery
is superior to a culture that practiced
slavery but has never apologized for it
let me guess this next question is where
you try to lean me down the path and say
oh first nations people haven't
apologized for slavery
no no therefore let's keep up with you
don't don't don't try and look down the
tunnel of time that's that's not being
honest just answer the question
is a culture that fought hard to end
slavery
and not just in its own domains in its
own countries but also around the world
to
to end the international practice of
slavery is a culture that burned
hundreds of thousands of lives and
trillions of dollars of blood and
treasure to end slavery around the world
and has apologized for slavery and
feels bad about it and has paid
reparations to some degree
do you think that a culture that has
apologized for slavery
and work to end slavery is morally
better than a culture
that has never apologized for slavery
okay i'm going to answer your question
and
the the the point has nothing to do with
indigenous people i'm going to answer
your question and then after this we're
going to have to wrap it up and leave
i will answer your question but if at
the end of this tunnel of time
it's going where i think it's going i'm
gonna be pissed
okay that's fair yes the answer is yes
i think obviously it's superior to a pop
for a nation who's apologized and made
reparations which we haven't right
so you must then be much more critical
of a muslim culture or islamic culture
which practice slavery at far greater
levels
than the europeans ever did and for far
longer and there are estimates that tens
of millions of blacks from africa were
killed
died as the result of slavery in the
muslim countries
so therefore you must believe that
western culture
is superior to muslim culture because
muslim culture to my knowledge has not
had a giant mia
culpa stare into the mirror
soul-searching repudiation of a history
of slavery i told if it was going where
i thought it was going i was going to be
pissed and you know exactly it's the
same thing you just swapped out one
brown people with first nations for
another
with muslims and i think that other
othering these kinds of people
every single argument that i hear is
marginalizing and as a citizen of the
world
as someone who sees myself as
compassionate as someone who does not
want to see
families torn apart as someone who's not
a hypocrite because they have no claim
to this land
i disagree with you and i think that
that's a dirty trick i told you i wasn't
going to be happy with it
and i'm not it's free domain radio if
i'm not mistaken
stephen thank you for taking the time i
don't think we'll be having you back
anytime soon you you did exactly what i
told
i said you better not i said you better
not and yeah better not use facts reason
and evidence man that's rough on you i
get it i get it i appreciate the
conversation man someone have my lighter
let's get them off devil's advocate
with skyler turton
seriously where's my [ __ ] lighter
guys
you